[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
boris johnson won't be the first person
in the world to discover that breaking
up is hard to do you don't have to be a
die-hard remainer to observe that
separation from continental europe isn't
quite as straightforward as many people
hoped
taking control of our borders hasn't
stopped the flow of migrants across the
channel from spiraling tenfold to
probably 25 000 this year
and the surge in kovidge infections has
prompted fresh lockdowns and rioting in
the eu and has health service bosses
looking nervously at the horizon as
winter approaches
of course no one can pin racism in
cricket on the neighbors our troubles in
the game we invented are all homegrown
we'll be discussing that and much more
with our guests this morning
coming up in the next hour we'll be
speaking to health secretary sajid javid
the shadow home secretary nick thomas
simmons joins us from cardiff
we've got chris hobson the chief
executive of nhs providers that's the
organization that presents represents
most hospitals in england
and one of the uk's most prominent
public health experts professor linda
bold
we'll also be hearing from the vice
chair of the northern powerhouse
partnership and lifelong manchester
united fan lord o'neill who we might
speculate has had a pretty tough week
but first let's go straight to the
health secretary sajid javed good
morning good morning
you've announced a review into the use
of oximeters which is which have led to
an underestimate of the treatment needs
of
people of color is that an admission
that our health services have a systemic
undeclared racial bias
you know what there may actually be a
health services across the world a a
systemic
racial bias i'm sad to say and this came
about because you know
there's lots of health disparities in in
our country there are in many countries
but we saw that i think quite acutely
during the covet crisis if you were from
a bme uh background you were
a third of admissions were from bme
background in in icu units at the height
of the crisis and that compares to
that's more than double the
representation in the population and i
asked my team to to look at this in some
detail i wanted to really understand
what was going on and one of the reasons
they came back with with was around
pulse oximeters a medical device that
you know tells you about your oxygen
level crucial with covert and combating
covid and from in many cases it was
giving false readings and you know what
really got me was that this was this was
already known there were research papers
already on this and no one did anything
about it now i'm not saying this was
deliberate by anyone i think it's just
it's a systemic issue potentially with
medical devices and it may go even
further than that with medical textbooks
for example and so
that's why i've uh announced today that
this is something i think that we should
do something about not just here in the
uk i want to work with my colleagues
across the world i've already talked to
my counterpart in the u.s and here's is
as interested in this as i am and uh and
see what we can do because clearly
something like this can never be
acceptable as you said this is not just
something we've discovered with kobe
this particular thing was known before
uh there's been lots of work which shows
that medical trials which i think you've
mentioned are frankly the the samples
which contain thousands of people are
often racially biased uh
not with not enough people of color in
them and of course um we've had a report
from a group of mps this week uh with
about the treatment of people with
sickle cell anemia who are almost
exclusively black uh and the
deficiencies in that um
bluntly
can
frankly people like you and me really
trust that the nhs is going to treat us
fairly
i think we can we can trust the nhs
but i think
of course we can uh and and let's not
you know the nhs has been there for all
of us for for for decades now and and
helped all
every community in britain and that's of
course uh something that is right but we
should always be looking to see what can
be done
to improve things and and this
particular issue about you know racial
bias in in medical instruments it's
global it's nothing to really i think
it's it's not really about the nhs it's
a it's a global issue these oximeters
are being used
across the world they all have the same
problem uh some of the other issues
we've come across and you've mentioned
around sickle cell anemia and things
these are global issues and i think
britain is in a place
to take some leadership on this and and
as i say as i've discussed it with my
counterparts there's some of them have
been surprised about this about the the
evidence i've presented them with but
they are all united in wanting to do
something about it and i hope that i'm
in a position over the next few years to
to do more about this and and let
britain take the lead all right this
week we've seen the return of lockdown
across uh europe do we need to prepare
for more restrictions here before
christmas well i think as we all look
forward to christmas it's very sad to
see cases rising you're surging in
certain parts of europe now we've always
known that this virus it loves the
winter it likes the cold darker days
that winter brings and we need to make
sure we're doing everything we can to
protect ourselves against that what's
made a real difference here in the uk is
our booster program our hugely
successful booster program almost 15
million booster jabs given already
covering some quarter of the population
over the age of 12 almost 400 000 a day
across the uk and that's making the
difference and we know that because just
this week there was more data published
after more studies that shows that the
protection you get from your booster the
changing of protection it almost doubles
from 50
to over 90
and i'll be extending the booster
program starting tomorrow to 40 to 49
year olds but you know
all of us we've all got a role to play
in this and in in our national
vaccination program and if you're
eligible for your waste your first shot
second shot or your third shot you'll
please come forward and let's look
forward to christmas together all the
same um as one of my australians friends
um
said about uh covert 19 just before they
went back into
a huge lockdown this thing is a tricky
bugger
shouldn't you be dusting off plan b
vaccine passport uh requirement for
masks just in case well the first thing
i'd say trevor if i made is that you
know we made a a tough decision back in
the start of the summer
other countries didn't follow our course
and we decided that of course we want to
start opening up and if you're going to
do that it's best to do it into summer
it's far safer to do it in summer sadly
other countries in europe did not do
that but looking ahead as we look down
towards winter we need to make sure that
we are
remain cautious we are not complacent in
any way i've mentioned the importance of
the booster program but in terms of any
other potential measures
we've said all along we've got plan a
and that's where we firmly are at the
moment if we needed to take further
measures with plan b then we would do so
but we're not at that point yeah but
i suppose what you've pinned all your
hopes on the vaccine
roll out successful booster program
going quite well
but isn't the truth here that this is a
disguised form frankly of herd immunity
either through
vaccines or through natural immunity
induced in those who've had covid um
isn't this really still pretty risky
um i i wouldn't i would accept the
the way you've put it really and if i
may and the reason is because of course
the the vaccines are hugely important
part of our protection against this this
horrible virus but you're beyond that
there's a lot else going on so you have
to basically let it go as far in the
hope that the vaccine would get ahead of
the spread no not at all if you look at
what else that we are doing look at our
testing system we have a juggernaut of a
testing system you have more than i
think any other country in europe in
terms of the availability of tests the
type of tests we have a a surveillance
program that is the envy of the world we
have you know have clear guidance out
there we've taken decisions for example
the one i announced last week around uh
nhs uh compulsory vaccinations for
people working the nhs in in your care
staff so
taking together i think these are of
course the right measures but where i
think you would be right of course we
need to remain cautious uh this thing
can be very unpredictable and we need to
be ready and monitor the data extremely
carefully and that's exactly what we do
but cautious relative to i mean even in
in the uk england is an outlier
yesterday at hamdan park uh fans were
required to show that they had been
double jab before they could get into
the
stadium today
man city are going to play everton 52
000 people no requirement to show you a
double jab i mean we are taking the
risky path but we we've made a decision
in this country to take a different path
in some ways we don't have uh the
so-called sort of vaccine passport if an
operator or a venue operator wants to
take additional measures that's up to
them but i think the package the balance
that we set out in plan a and then
making sure that we've got contingency
measures in place the so-called plan b i
think's been the right path has been
proven to be the right path i think we
can safely say that so far but as i say
we can't be complacent and can i also
mention the flu jabs the flu jabs are a
hugely important part of our winter plan
and we're seeing record numbers of
people come forward for those as well
it's the biggest flu vaccination program
this country has seen and that's just as
important this winter as covert booster
shots well look you know i
forgive me for banging on about the risk
here but we know what the real issue is
uh that the nhs will be overwhelmed i'm
going to talk to chris hopson uh the the
boss of nhs providers later and he's
going to tell me that it's it's dire you
yourself have said that waiting lists
could climb as high as 13 million do you
happen to know by the way where we are
on waiting lists this weekend what's the
number
it's five point nine million roughly
enough for elective people waiting for
uh elective procedures is around 5.9
million and as i've said i've been
really clear this number is going to go
up before it comes down why because some
seven to eight million people stayed
away during the height of the coveted
crisis because they were asked to they
did what was asked of them but i want
them to come forward i want them to come
back to the nhs i want them to know that
it is open to them and if you take that
along with normal demand of course
that's huge pressure and can i say
you're right to talk about the pressure
on the nhs it is you're significant and
and i think everyone working the nhs and
certainly from everything i hear
everything i've seen they are doing an
absolutely amazing job and they will get
all the support that we can possibly
provide 5.9 million are you actually
going to wait till we hit 13 million
before you do something like for example
bring the nightingale hospitals back in
the 13 million number was if we carried
on with business as usual of course what
we've what we've done in the in the last
couple of months has set out our plans
for the longer term not just this winter
but over the longer term with with with
the new funding settlement for the nhs
which will allow us to invest more
whether it's in the workforce but at
what number will you decide to do
something like what they're doing in
scotland what they're doing in wales
what they're doing across the continent
to
to arrest the spread of transmission are
you just going to wait no that that
trevor if i say that's more around
winter pressure the elective procedures
back that will take time it's not just a
question over the winter it's going to
take the time after the winter of course
to continue to work through those people
that are waiting for procedures over the
winter in particular that where as we
know you know covid particularly likes
the winter we set out our plan a but
when it comes to winter pressures for
the nhs and where they are significant i
readily accept that is that that's where
we've provided more support an extra 5.4
billion pounds of funding over this
winter for the nhs and for the care
system because they're very you know
linked
in in helping to deal with winter
pressures and that has provided support
for example for more 999 callers 111
ambulance services discharge a discharge
fund for for people that are ready to be
clinically discharged from hospital but
a care place that can't easily be found
so more funding for that so all of this
is helping and and let me be clear i'm
not pretending for a second that that
this is uh
you're going to take away all the
pressure of the winter of course not we
normally have tough winters and with
kobit it's going to be even harder but i
think the nhs is doing a fantastic job
and we will support them in every way we
possibly can all right let's talk about
another source of pressure on the
government
not that you haven't got enough already
but we know that there have been record
numbers of people landing on the beaches
from the continent this uh this weekend
um
in 15 months you were home secretary
uh we saw fewer than 2 000 a year
landing um in 2020 that number
quadrupled to 8 400 and we know this
year it's increased to 24 000. that's
ten
ten times the number when you were in
office um would you have tolerated this
uh this kind
of breach of our borders well the first
thing is to say is that we are seeing a
huge rise in irregular migration across
the world including of course
europe and sadly we're seeing many of
these your people smugglers these
criminals these var criminals that are
exploiting uh people and what we're
seeing in the channel is is that that
you know that sort of so-called business
model of these smugglers i mean this
this route this 21 mile route across the
channel that this is some of the most
dangerous waters in the world it's one
of the busiest shipping lanes in the
world and no one should be risking their
life across this and it's the people
smugglers that are to blame for this and
it's right that the home secretary is
looking at every option that there is to
try and break this business that's all
true but
the na the words take back control echo
in my head and it seems to me that the
last thing that's happened was that
we've taken back any control in fact
we've handed it over to the people
smugglers would you have tolerated this
number crossing the channel were you
home secretary well no no one will
tolerate this number but the home
sector she's doing a huge amount of work
in trying to break this business model
so the the nationality and borders build
that she's brought in front of
parliament now coming back to the house
of commons soon that is setting out a
whole bunch of new measures and actions
we can take and let's let's be clear on
this trevor that
people
that are
this country has a great track record
rightly so of providing security and
protection to those people who are
genuinely fleeing persecution and we've
done that recently just with afghanistan
and and has been right to do that but we
do have to ask ourselves is that if
people are trying to get to the uk from
safe countries like france are they
genuine asylum seekers or not and it is
right to ask that and it is right to
change the rules to to to take that into
account and that's what the home
secretary is doing all right one quick
uh last point on this um how the talks
with removing them to albania or rwanda
going i'm not gonna comment in any
speculation nice try i don't think you
expect me to say anything else
all right let's talk about cricket and
race now i assume you'll have followed
like everybody else the dramatic
revelations
from yorkshire um
can you empathize with as the azim rafiq
stories
are there things in your own experience
that
with which this resonates yes of course
and when i
when i first heard about this and that
was uh when i really looked at it was
when the the i think it was a leak of
the report that the the the club had
done on this issue
and it really just shocked me in this in
this day and age that the the people
doing this report would have these views
that somehow being called
is banter it's it's it's not it never
has been and uh
and yeah you asked me about personal
experience yeah when i was growing up as
a kid i was cool almost every day at
school i didn't like it then i don't
like it now
i think the good news is our country has
come a long long way
since then but clearly not every
institution in the country has taken
that journey and it's clear to everyone
now that yorkshire county cricket club
is one of those institutions that has
been stuck in the dark ages and needs to
change that process of change i think
with lord patel that has has begun but
there's going to be a long way to go and
the ecb should be doing its job to make
sure that this is
taken seriously throughout cricketing in
the uk
uh just in passing i noticed that
and it's interesting you can use the p
word i obviously cannot uh it's an
interesting question about how we deal
and talk about these things but a
specific um question really we've been
talking about all of these things and
you and i have talked about it before
cricket football in politics
when the government uh thought that the
incursions on freedom of speech in
universe was getting were getting out of
hand it has intervened there's a new
piece of legislation
don't you think it's time seeing what
we're seeing on football more complaints
from football refugees this morning
daily revelations about cricket isn't it
time for the government essentially to
stop trusting the sporting authorities
the ecb fn all of that who clearly
from what we've seen failed and for the
government to step in in the way it has
done in universities on freedom of
speech well i think it's a very good
question because i think the the
sporting authorities
yeah whether it's football cricket they
they talk the talk but you know what
what have they actually done that's
really helping and you know i remember
when i was the culture secretary and
overseeing you know sport in this
country i remember meeting the ecb then
about issues of
racial discrimination in cricket and
they were telling me what they're going
to do and look where we are now many
years later look at what's happening
look at what's being uncovered i don't
think the ecb has taken this issue very
seriously i think they need to take a
long hard look at themselves and now
this is a real test for them and uh and
let's see if they can pass it and if
they fail that test
then let's wait and see that's going to
be decision for the culture secretary
but i will say this that the culture
secretary the current culture secretary
takes this issue just as seriously as i
do
health secretary thank you very much
indeed thank you
now the uk government this week
announced a review into how to prevent
migrants crossing the english channel
topic we've just been discussing with
the health secretary more than 1 000
people made that dangerous crossing in a
single day earlier this month and both
the labour party and many conservative
mps believe more action is needed the
shadow home secretary nick thomas
simmons is in cardiff
good morning mr thomas simmons
now
you've crunched the numbers
you've corroborated what we knew that
the there are record numbers of people
crossing the channel 300 in 2018 more
than 24 000 now
um is it is the point that you were
really trying to make that you think
that pretty patel is being too soft on
undocumented migrants
uh good morning trevor good to join you
no the point i'm making is that the home
secretary is comprehensively failing in
this policy area and it appears the
prime minister agrees because he seems
to be putting the minister for the
cabinet office
in charge of a review of this but the
home secretary's failure is a dangerous
failure we have thousands of people
risking their lives in these most
dangerous sea lanes the most dangerous
sea crossing in the world and if the
rate continues as it is at the moment
if the rate of increase from last year
to this year is repeated again next year
we'll have as many people risking their
lives in the channel as there are people
in pretty patel's constituency her
incompetence on this issue is dangerous
yes but let's just get clear why you
think pretty patella is failing
is she failing because she's not getting
people ashore safely
or is she failing because she's letting
anybody assure at all
it what what is the problem with what
she's doing that she's failing to stop
the people getting here or that she's
allowing people to be endangered
let me tell you exactly what the problem
is and exactly what i would be doing as
home secretary in stead
we need first of all to have a workable
deal with the french authorities which
pretty patel doesn't have all she's
interested in is diplomatic spats with
the french government that isn't uh what
we need what we actually need is to be
looking not only at the coast not only
at the coastal patrols but we need to be
looking as well as what what is
happening away from the coast disrupting
these vile people smugglers on the
routes that they facilitate people do
not become refugees in northern france
this problem is about a far wider issue
than that second but
second the government should reintroduce
the dub scheme which is a safe route for
unaccompanied children three thousand
unaccompanied children was meant to help
close then after 480 and finally thirdly
let me just finish on this point the
government should reinstate the
international aid budget the 0.7
and the department for international
development which tackled why
people become displaced from their homes
in the first place so that's what i'd be
doing and that i'm afraid of what pretty
patel is failing on at the moment
yes forgive me i i still don't really
understand what your objective is here
is your objective to provide
safe travel for 25 000 people who want
to land in britain or is your objective
to stop 25 000 people who want to land
in britain
coming short the beaches
my objective is to stop people risking
their lives in the english channel in
the first place one person risking their
life in the english channel is one too
many i i've been to dover
you want to you basically want to stop
you want to stop the you want to stop
people coming here that's the basic
that's the bottom line here
no
hang on no that that's that's not quite
what i'm saying at all i've already
mentioned the issue of safe routes and
i've already said that would be a
fundamental part of what i would be
doing as home secretary but what i'm
also saying to you trevor is that we
have to prevent people risking their
lives in the english channel because
that is what is happening on a virtual
daily basis at the moment and pretty
patel is comprehensively failing to
prevent that from happening
okay well
there's a perfectly reasonable way to
stop people risking their lives which is
that when uh our uh our boats our uh
navy sees them in the channel take them
aboard and bring them back to
back to dover so that's fine 25 000
people landing on the beaches that's
okay
uh saving lives in the english channel
is of course okay and by the way people
who demonize the royal national lifeboat
institute for saving lives at sea should
be absolutely ashamed of themselves
frankly once people's lives are at risk
nobody's doing that here see we have to
make sure we save those lives the point
i'm making is we need our policy to be
calibrated in such a way that people are
not risking their lives in the channel
in the first place and that is where
pretty vital is failing comprehensively
all right well let's let's just talk
about um the proposals that uh you put
out today um when you talk about safe
and legal routes to help prevent people
from using people trafficking routes um
an example of such i mean how does that
work
well i'll give you i'll give you two
specific examples trevor let me give you
the first example which i mentioned a
moment or two ago which is the dubs
scheme named after alf dubs who escaped
nazi persecution on the kinder transport
in the 1930s
that should be reinstated everybody
across parliament understood that would
have helped three thousand unaccompanied
children the government closed it down
after only 480 that needs to be
reinstated secondly we really do need to
see the government's action on the
afghanistan resettlement scheme we've
had operation meeting where our armed
forces did a magnificent job in that
airlift
from kabul airport but what we've seen
from the government is nothing in terms
of how they propose now to help those
people that they've promised to help but
my worry is that unless the government
gets that right that safe route right we
are going to end up in a situation where
the possible tragedy next year of seeing
people from afghanistan in the english
channel unless the government gets this
right now
of dub scheme was as you say
in a sense inspired by his own
experience as a child of the
kindertransport
who escaped
nazi occupation and so on um but what is
different here is that the children that
we're seeing in the channel have their
parents with them um
if the scheme were implemented it would
also follow by the way it wouldn't just
be three thousand children it would be
their parents wouldn't it um and that
that's that's you that would be part of
your scheme with it
well look there's already we're already
looking at in the issue of family
reunion but let's not just mix up uh
issues here because the people who've
all right this is the natural
consequence of what you suggested isn't
it
well it's certainly family reunion is
something that is already being
considered and looked at but the point
i'm making is we mustn't mix up issues
here in the sense that those who've
already arrived here trevor that you've
just referred to
clearly the issue for them and 98 of
those who arrive claim asylum is that
their asylum claim is dealt with quickly
and fairly and one of the other major
problems for this government is what
they've done to the asylum system over
the past 11 years if you go back to 2014
87 of asylum claims were dealt with
within six months by 2019 that had
fallen to 20 the government made a
catastrophic blunder in taking away the
six-month performance target in our
asylum system and what we're left with
now is a situation in our asylum system
where claims are taking in some cases
many years it's not helpful to anyone in
our asylum system it's not helpful to
the taxpayer it is a failure of this
conservative government
um i don't know if you heard the health
secretary uh talking about
uh first of all the uh essentially
institutional systemic racism in health
services not just in the uk across the
world and i wondered what your thought
was about that
and secondly the prospect of
more people
than the 5.9 million um who are waiting
for treatment in the nhs and pick your
either those two issues
well firstly in terms of the
disproportionate
impact of healthcare on black asian
minority ethnic communities that's
something labor has been raising
throughout the pandemic
kia sama appointed baroness doreen
lawrence to look at this and the next
labor government will introduce a new
race equality act to look at precisely
those disproportionate
outcomes
travel i think that is absolutely
essential and top priority that we do as
regards the national health service in
england this winter we are in a
situation where this week the government
with completely the wrong priorities
will try to drive through another yet
another top-down reorganization when we
need urgent action in our national
health service now here in wales where
i'm speaking to you from where labor is
in government we've set out a winter
plan we are focusing here in wales the
labour party on that investment to go
into social services to reduce pressure
on the nhs throughout the winter the
government for england doesn't have a
plan to deal with this and should be
putting its foot to the floor put the
pedal down on the booster program to get
that booster program really up to half a
million jobs a day that will be one of
the most effective ways of reducing
pressure on the nhs in england this
winter
nick thomas simmons thank you very much
thank you
even before the pandemic staff and
hospital bed shortages were leading to
serious problems in the nhs
but for nearly two years now doctors
have been battling the biggest public
health crisis since spanish flu in 1918.
and now there's an enormous cue for
treatment and waiting times are at their
highest since records began
i'm joined now by chris hopson the chief
executive of nhs providers which
represents most hospitals in england
good morning chris um
nhs leaders like yourself uh say that uh
you're worried about how the health
system is going to cope this winter
juggling the pressures of clover 19 flu
and the care
backlog
how serious is this going to be
well we are on an under an unprecedented
degree of pressure for this time of year
and what we're experiencing is uh very
very high levels of volume of people
coming into accident emergency
departments we know we've got
the ambulance services under real
pressure but wherever you look trevor
right the way across the nhs be in
community services be in mental health
services be it in hospitals the nhs is
under an unprecedented degree of
pressure for this time of year and of
course that's before the traditional
winter peak we know that the nhs tends
to feel most pressure
in early to mid january so there is a
high degree of concern but look let me
just say one thing really really
importantly which is that obviously this
is what the nhs is here for we're here
to provide the best quality of care to
everybody who needs it and our staff are
working absolutely flat out to ensure
that we deliver in line with the nhs
constitution because that's what we're
here for
but the elastic doesn't stretch
infinitely does it i mean um
sagi javed talked uh earlier this month
about the potential
for waiting lists to climb to 13 million
he says well of course uh that would be
if they hadn't done anything but um
how high do you think it could get and
could this be
a moment of permanent damage to the nhs
i think it's very difficult to predict
trevor because we simply don't know how
many people who didn't come forward
during covet 19 during the pandemic will
actually come forward and therefore we
are in a bit of a guessing game about
exactly how many but the bit i can
assure you is that nhs staff and nhs
leaders are working incredibly hard at
the moment to create that plan uh to
ensure that we can get through that
backlog as quickly as possible and let
me just give you a couple of stats um
which is that for example you know
after the january and february peaking
covered this year
we actually hit a very very high peak of
the number of people waiting for more
than a year so we hit 430 000 people but
hey look by um october we've actually
cut that peak by a third because we're
going flat out so what we're seeing is
that staff are going as fast as they
possibly can to ensure we get through
elective activity as quickly as possible
but we are working under some real
really important constraints here i mean
for example you know if you talk to an
average district general hospital chief
exec you know they'll probably have on
average 500 beds what they're saying to
us at the moment is 75 of those beds are
out of action because they're
effectively uh we've had to take them
out for covert infection control 50 of
them are currently filled by covert
patients and 50 of them they've got
medically fit patients to discharge but
we can't discharge them partly because
of the pressure on social care has taken
another big
leap and it's got significantly greater
over the last few months so you've got
175 of your 500 beds are out of action
at a point 35 percent of your bed base
is out of action
in terms of for non-covered care and we
know that in winter we're using
98 99 100 capacity of those beds so it's
not entirely surprising that at this
point because of covid because of the
pressure on social care because of the
workforce pressures that we actually
don't have the capacity in the nhs that
we need and that is one of the real
things that everybody needs to realize
we've gone through a decade of the
longest and deepest financial squeeze in
nhs history so we've not been able to
grow our capacity to meet that growing
demand we're putting huge pressure on
our workforce and social care is
continuing to come under greater greater
pressure and those four pressures have
been literally have been growing for a
decade and effectively you can't just
turn around and you know solve all of
them by turning on a sixpence it's going
to take time for the nhs to get back to
an even keel and to recover from covid
we do know from experience though how
that
when we hit capacity
where the system gives and that is in
the fact that people have to wait and
particularly
distressing i think is uh that they have
to wait in emergencies the royal college
of emergency medicine says that more
than 4
500 people died following 12-hour waits
in a d department in england last year
now and they're reports of people dying
in ambulances while waiting
uh outside hospitals i mean are we gonna
see more of that this winter
well we know that what happens
trevor is that when pressure increases
the nhs doesn't break it doesn't fall
over
it doesn't reach a tipping point what
happens exactly as you say is that
pressure comes on weights people have to
wait longer we know that patient safety
becomes more at risk and we also know
that the quality of care comes under
pressure but again i just really want to
repeat this this is what nhs staff are
used to dealing with i mean to be frank
they're probably too used to dealing
with it
in terms of the degree of pressure that
we're under we will do everything we can
to ensure we provide the best quality of
care but yes you're right um the patient
safety risk will increase trevor the
other thing that i think it's important
to really talk about is the workforce
we've got 93 000 staff vacancies we're
spending 6 billion pounds in terms of to
cover those vacancies and we're now
asking the nhs to do the impossible and
as nick
nick simon thomas was saying earlier
this week the government will be
debating the health and care bill we've
got to have a proper approach to
long-term workforce planning and jeremy
hunt with a group of cross-party mps
greens snp liberal democrats labour and
a large number of conservative mps are
basically saying to the government in
their amendment to the health and care
bill this week we have to have a proper
approach to long-term workforce planning
and that will help us avoid this endless
repetition of problems in winter
thank you because i wanted to come to
this issue of staff um
everything you said is completely
understandable but of course you can't
magic
uh trained skilled qualified staff out
of nowhere um and worse still you can
make it uh less attractive for people to
serve in the health service you recently
said that you thought that the
introduction of mandatory vaccinations
for nhs staff could make the staffing
situation even worse
why and actually do you think the
government simply just ought to drop
that plan
i i think trevor we know that life gets
particularly difficult when you have two
competing objectives and when you've got
two sets of people who've got in a sense
competing rights and it's quite right i
mean i've been very struck by the you
know post bag i've had from patients who
are saying i think it's my right to
ensure that i'm treated by a member of
staff who's been double vaccinated and i
know whether they've been double
vaccinated or not equally i've had quite
a few really strong
emails and letters from members of staff
who feel very strongly it's their human
right to decide whether they get
vaccinated or not and they get to decide
what they should put in their bodies and
the problem that you've got here is
you've got those two conflicting rights
what we've said is we understand the
logic as to why the government
is going for mandatory vaccination but
what we've said really clearly is that
they need to work with us over the next
few months before that april deadline
arrives so that we can ensure that as
many staff as possible voluntarily kind
of take up um the vaccination and we
know that the best way of doing that is
by having patient encouraging supportive
conversations where we really understand
why people have these misplaced and they
are misplaced fears about why they
shouldn't be vaccinated work through
with those those concerns and then
persuade them to be vaccinated and again
you know what's particularly interesting
is we know that there are particular
demographic groups that have got high
levels of vaccine hesitancy we know for
example that
people are colleagues from black
communities we also know that um women
who are thinking of getting uh pregnant
relatively soon they're they're people
who've got higher rates of vaccine
hesitancy and what what our chief execs
tell us is if you can have a
peer-to-peer conversation with people
from the same group explaining why
some members of that group most members
of that group have had the vaccination
it can be very successful but we just
need to do this in a calm patient and
encouraging and supportive way because
if we don't we really do face a major
issue in terms of losing very
significant members of staff just at the
point where we can't afford to do so
well some of those people who
are as you put it vaccine hesitant
i mean they're they're medics they are
health uh practitioners uh it's not like
they're ignorant about this uh and some
just won't be persuaded uh where in the
end are you gonna come down on this are
you going to say that ultimately at some
point
if people won't have the jab
they simply can't work in your hospitals
well that's where we've got to that's
what the government has been very clear
about we're waiting for the detailed
guidance but all of us in the nhs expect
that if if staff haven't been vaccinated
by that first of april deadline they
will no longer be able to provide
frontline care i mean there is obviously
the opportunity to explore with people
about whether we can uh redeploy them to
uh non-front-line care areas but that's
what the government
has decided um needs to be done but as i
said trevor the key the key is for us to
work with our staff to try and maximize
um you know the number of people
who do take up the vaccine voluntarily
chris hopson thank you very much indeed
thank you trevor
austria has ordered a full national
lockdown begins on monday
cases are rising fast across northern
europe with the health minister in
neighbouring germany describing a
national emergency
in the netherlands there have been riots
over new restrictions three people were
seriously injured in rotterdam and
police fired warning shots at protesters
i'm joined now by professor linda bold a
public health expert at edinburgh
university good morning professor bold
good to see you again morning trevor
now um there's a fourth wave sweeping
the
continent with countries like austria as
i've said recording record numbers um
how worried should we be about
that surge in infections uh on the
continent
we're all looking with with grave
concern actually and trying to determine
whether there are differences in the
situation in europe um or whether it's
just a matter of time until this faces
us here i mean just briefly to be a bit
more optimistic there are some reasons
why there might be a different
trajectory delta the variant we're
dealing with now became dominant
particularly in central europe later
than it did in the uk we opened up a
little bit earlier particularly in
england and so we dealt with our delta
wave in the summer and early autumn
we're still in it of course but not
those big rises and and then the other
features are around unfortunately
because we've had high infections in the
past we probably a bit more natural
immunity in the population as an
immunity post infection particularly for
younger groups who've not been eligible
for vaccines and then the other thing is
that the vaccine rollout in europe if
you look at the population level these
countries you're talking about
netherlands even more vaccines than us
austria a little bit lower germany
roughly similar and but they deliver
their second doses earlier for many
older groups they're certainly seeing
waning now and they've also got in some
parts of the population some pockets of
hesitancy which are causing real concern
so it may not be the same but you know
it's very uncertain
uh well i want to come to the issue of
waning immunity in a second but before
we get there i mean
in a way there's an example
uh much closer to home for us in england
and that is where you are in scotland
where in spite of what you said about
the uh factors that might uh lead us to
be more optimistic the scottish
government has essentially been tougher
uh particularly in relation to
uh transmission risk and has taken steps
to reduce transmission risks which are
not being taken uh in england um
does that worry you should
we we in england be following the
example that you have in scotland
well i think if you look across the
devolved nations actually trevor
throughout this pandemic there have been
slight differences i mean let's just
look at face coverings for example
you're right that is still required up
here as it is in northern ireland wales
in some settings that it's not in
england and if you look at the surveys
people are far more likely to report
they are wearing them here even though i
don't think compliance is 100 by any
stretch so that's a factor we still have
stronger advice to work from home and
then of course
we have a modest certification scheme
wales has just expanded theirs on monday
i mean we've continually had this
question about should the uk use the
same approach across all four nations my
personal views is confusing when the
guidance is different but on the other
hand the developed nations have
authority in relation to public health
and indeed the nhs it's that it's a
devolved responsibility
and so we'll see at the moment if you
look at the ons infection survey levels
of infection in scotland are a bit lower
than they are in england we've got real
concerns about northern ireland it's
really difficult to make those direct
comparisons but of course i would prefer
that people were wearing a face covering
in public places and trying to follow
those protective behaviors to keep
themselves and others as safe as
possible
can you talk to us about uh about this
issue of waning immunity what's the
evidence that the
um protection offered by uh double
jabbing is waning uh in a meaningful way
or a way that should affect policy
well you've got two different types of
evidence there the first one is real
world where you can look at large
epidemiological studies that just show
what the risk is of being infected of um
becoming unwell and going into hospital
depending on the duration or between
your second dose and when that event
occurs and you can see that those who
have their second doses earlier there's
more evidence of waning you also get
that from studies like react where
they're looking at a random sample of
people in the in the population who are
swapped that's that's one source of
evidence and then the second of course
is from the trials for the pfizer trial
for example where they looked at the
effectiveness of boosters they were able
to look at some of those features so
it's very clear that there is waning
it's not uniform across groups
but obviously people have more
vulnerabilities if they have underlying
health conditions or they're older and
those groups got the vaccine first in
most countries and so i think it's
pretty clear from that evidence and also
from the studies that have been done in
israel for example looking at what a
booster can do
getting that protection for example from
antibodies for say fifty percent
uh six months post second dose as it
wanes right back to over ninety percent
and that's what we're trying to achieve
here in the uk
well it's um
it's evident now that everybody thinks
that the booster is important and in
fact there's some suggestion that um the
booster gives you
a better coverage um i've had mine i i
guess i'm now told that i'm 93 95 96
uh protected um
it is now going to become part of our
life like the flu
jab every year that we're going to have
to have some kind of booster against
covet
i think that's scientifically uncertain
at the moment i'm not a virologist or an
immunologist but speaking to those
colleagues it's pretty clear that that
is a possibility the great thing about
the boosters trevor and i cannot
emphasize enough the importance of
people taking up that offer or going
online for people in my age group and
booking their appointment asap six
months
second dose please please do it it's the
key for this winter and is that it it
kicks in almost within seven days if you
look at some of the studies or or we
have an immune memory that responds
again to that vaccine it's possible like
influenza as you point out that we will
have repeat delivery of boosters in
future uh particularly for older age
groups but we don't know that yet we
need to study in the in real time the
effect of these vaccine programs and see
and see what happens but you know back
to the first question you asked me if we
can really continue to deliver boosters
at scale we can continue to be cautious
in our behavior and try and adopt those
protective behaviors even if they're not
mandated everywhere
you know i'm really hoping we can
despite what chris said about the huge
pressures on the nhs get through this
winter without it being a disaster and
without us having the situation we had
last christmas
the um the health secretary rather
dismissed
my question
that uh
essentially in truth what the
government's doing even though it's not
called this is pursuing a strategy
of herd immunity of course that's become
a sort of dirty phrase but in truth that
actually what they're hoping is a
combination of induced immunity and
natural immunity will as you just just
said protect us through this winter now
he's got to say that because he's a
politician you don't uh is that in truth
what's happening here
i think if you look at children there
certainly has been a strategy just to
allow this infection to go through our
young populations that's very clear to
me
different governments around the uk have
had different views on that and of
course we've had to follow the guidance
of experts on the jcvi but i think
you know if you look at the minutes from
that committee in terms of the decisions
that they took they have huge expertise
but if you look at the minutes and if
you look at some of the narrative
particularly at uk level it certainly
has been the case that this is a mild
infection in children it's probably
better that they just get it i don't
think that's been a strategy for older
age groups um you know we're worried
about long covered uh the risks are not
year zero to young people i would like
12 to 15 year olds to be able to have
their second dose i would like us to
consider what's happening in the us with
vaccines for younger children in the
long term i think to have protection
through vaccination
if it's safe and irrespective of age is
far preferable to allowing it to happen
just on mass through natural infection
professor bold thank you very much as
ever
now the red wall crumbled this weekend i
am of course referring to manchester
united for one thrashing at
watford but any fans hoping that one day
they could get to old trafford on the
new northern powerhouse rail line from
leeds have also had their hopes dashed
that transport project has been
cancelled along with the eastern leg of
hs2
i am joined now by lord o'neal former
treasury minister and vice chair of the
northern powerhouse partnership good
morning lord o'neal
please call me jim trevor good morning
um
one of my colleagues said to me
yesterday uh
is what the government did this week
a boost to the northern powerhouse or
does it really feel like the great train
robbery to you
well i have to i laugh to myself as a
manchester united fan when you introduce
the topic
i'm not sure who's handling uh priority
matters worse the glazer family with
united or
boris and his team with this i mean
you know they're both they're both
absolutely shambolic to be honest with
you the as my
uh
ex-chancellor when i was a briefly a
minister said i think to the ft
yesterday that
who would who would have thought
announcing a package close to 100
billion pounds could go down so badly
and
i think i think there's two problems the
first one is
uh
this government
seems to be uh completely inept to
expectations management um
you know this is a government that's
taught i think
factually somewhere between 60 and 70
times about delivering northern
powerhouse rail in full
which which is
right at the core of the whole idea of
the northern powerhouse concept which
obviously
i'm in the middle of um
and uh they they've sort of penny
pinched um
but you know if this would have been the
first time that ever made a policy
announcement about northern powerhouse
rail it might not have gone down quite
as badly as it has but
what they've managed to do is is
disappoint virtually everybody including
manchester by the way because as much as
they still got hs2 and all the bits of
northern powerhouse rail they haven't
got what they wanted at the station
either
and of course the key part of the
agglomeration is it's not really linking
us up to
leads properly
which was supposed to be the priority
first part
uh of northern powerhouse rail and
indeed the integrated rail plan so
you know in isolation if it would have
just appeared from nowhere it might not
have been so bad but given everything
that's followed since uh boris johnson
became prime minister as as we can see
with the reaction across the board it's
pretty disappointing so so both so the
problem is both substance and handling
and by the way we'll come to the
football question a bit later but um
let
let's uh
listen to what uh grant shaps the
transport secretary said or let me
remind you what he said that um
the
government
plan would
halve journey times in some parts of the
north uh
from manchester to leeds and so on by
upgrading surely that's a win of some
description
well you know i've spent a lot of time
on it and i
you know i keep trying to uh
chat with real uh rail engineering
experts because indeed
if the government's plan delivers six
trains an hour from leeds to manchester
in 33 minutes
uh that is pretty good
but the the problem is uh with what they
have specifically said they're going to
do
i i'm yet to find a single technical
expert that believes it's deliverable
because they've got a new new line from
leeds to huddersfield
but from huddersfield uh on leads it's
essentially a a planned upgrade of the
existing one and as anybody that travels
uh across the penins on that line never
mind the m62 knows
you know the the the line doesn't seem
to be capable enough of dealing with
what it has now never mind more in the
future so
it's just
if if one could take for 100
certainty
the great powers of digitalization uh
which which is implicitly instrumental
to this new plan
then it would be fantastic but that
that's sort of assuming that the life
and delivery of any kind of
infrastructure in the uk always works so
smoothly and we know it we know it
doesn't
the people who i suppose feel most
aggrieved are
uh people of bradford who
as you i think have pointed out um have
the youngest
workforce in the uk unfortunately that
workforce now can't really travel to the
places where there are the the jobs is
that
if you like
the central problem
that with what the government's done
that you have that it's not really
joining up
the metropolitan areas of uh the north i
mean you know when i in the early days
of trying to get uh the northern
powerhouse the idea adopted i used to
sort of in elegantly call it manchester
leeds pool
because if you take manchester to any of
those other three cities the distance is
less than the central line tube line in
london so the whole idea is to
try and get all the people that live
within that area
uh whether they be producers or
consumers it's about eight million
people to be able to move around as
easily as people do on the london uh
transport system and to have it all
integrated
and obviously for people in bradford
they they
they've got a they've got a sort of
token gesture of electrification from
bradford to leeds but that means they've
got to go the opposite way
in order to go to manchester afterwards
and
obviously that that's like going from
say i don't know
um
richmond out to out to reading before
you come back into london so obviously
for people from bradford it's
particularly unhelpful but i would add
again trevor that you know those of us
that have been following it with great
closeness for the past couple of years
they could have handled that better
because it seemed quite obvious to me
that the bradford link wouldn't happen
but yet uh they've allowed a lot of
people to think that it would
uh because it is quite the the bradford
bit to do
uh and have the train going through
bradford would be quite expensive but
i've i've seen since and here's another
thing to throw in given the the politics
of all of this
and interestingly how the labour
opposition is now
seemingly saying even more powerfully
than i recall them saying in the past
that they would deliver in full
including bradford the political
pressures might come back
uh and get them to rethink again i mean
the one thing is for sure with all this
never-ending nonsense surrounding
northern transport
is there's always some other idea in the
next couple of years so i i hope in this
case this is not the end of northern
powerhouse rail because whilst there are
bigger issues than transport northern
powerhouse rail is essential to the
whole idea that i helped create
well you're talking about the politics
of it and you're right most people
wherever they are aren't going to be
paying too much attention to the detail
of it but i suppose that the politics of
this week
could look like that actually this is a
government which essentially uh thinks
first about the south and the north gets
the leavings in a sense london has
crossrail and nothing has been allowed
to get in the way of delivering that
delays higher pr higher costs all sorts
of issues and planning and so on uh so
but crossrail is going to happen come
what may but suddenly
the north buff you're not getting the
thing that as you say everybody thought
you were going to get
well let's see whether they they they
revise that because of course
the downside of very strong expectations
creation is that it does create belief
and and and
a spirit and a desire and a passion
and so and that's partly what created
the victory for them in the election but
if they want to stay in power
uh they've obviously got to show some
evidence of following through
um i i would add in addition uh i i
smell that there is been quite a bit of
the hand of the treasury playing around
to try and save a few billion here and
there in the background but again for a
strategic government that judges risk
reward of these things properly
you know from what i can see they're
basically trying to save about four
billion by not going all the way through
to leeds from the original
announced plan for northern powerhouse
rail and it doesn't re given the amount
of money we're talking about here that's
about 10 percent of what was the
original total and that seems to me to
be a bad risk rewards judgment from
people in the treasury as well to be
honest
okay i can't let you go without asking
you what might be called the manchester
city question arising out of all of this
which is that um
i
but for fans of manchester united there
is some quite good news here because uh
the high-speed line will continue to run
from the south uh to birmingham and then
on to manchester united so that huge
percentage of manchester united fans who
don't come from manchester united
they're still going to be able to get to
old trafford aren't they
they they might find out if things carry
on the way that they're going that they
don't want to go there too much anymore
manchester united needs uh
needs owners that have uh profit with
purpose rather than uh no purpose
whatsoever completely shambolic how
they're presiding over this fiasco
complete
completely shambolic
well thank you jim o'neill for that um
that's considered
considered a nuanced judgment on the
government's performance thus far
that's about the glaze as that last part
by the way trevor oh sorry i beg your
pardon
okay
there we go all right well look that is
uh as much as we have time for today i
would have loved to carry on talking
about uh the premier league since my
team is at the top but um
we are going to end trevor phillips on
sunday for for the moment but of course
we'll be back with the take after the
break
[Music]